This case here is correct for the following reasons, x₃ is just as it is--there's not a not.
What that means is that if we take the path that signifies x₃ is set to true
and we know that is the path that goes like this.
Then we want to be able to visit this vertex here by paying so to say
just one extra edge, so that's exactly this one here.
If we had not x3 here, then this answer here would have been correct.
It seems like this is actually a good idea to show that any Boolean formula can be transformed
into a graph such that the shortest path between A and B tells us whether the original
Boolean formula had a satisfying assignment or not, but of course we haven't proved it yet
and that is why we will now have to go into gory details in order to actually prove
that we can reduced SAT to shortest tour.